[inaudible],
the Islamic Republic of Iran.
It's that country that makes these
independent movies you claim to enjoy
bits of never actually watched.
This country is also well known in a
rather different regard as being one of
the United States isn't main enemies as
well as being something of an antagonist
in Europe and in the democratic world in
general,
Iran is an Islamic theocracy where the
head of state is not even a politician,
but a religious leader.
The Ayatollah Jones,
the legal system is based on sharia law
and torture and to executions are pretty
common in the country.
Oh,
and just in case that wasn't enough,
the government's also fun.
Several terrorist groups all over the
world.
Important bleed.
This one called,
hold on just a second because I mean the
same is true of Saudi Arabia.
Nonetheless,
the Saudis,
I'll run a major ally of the United
States and to have important commercial
relationships with the rest of the
world.
So why is it wrong and seen as bad?
Well,
Saudi Arabia is seen as good by some
western governments.
Many would believe that the answer is a
pretty simple one.
Then that would be oil,
but the truth is that Iran has the
fourth biggest oil reserves in the
world.
Well,
the,
their crude oil is similar to that in
Saudi Arabia.
However,
just one year ago they had a band,
meaning that they couldn't sell it to
most of the world's countries.
Yep.
You heard that writes for years,
both America and Europe didn't want to
buy anything that came from this
country,
so now you might be wondering why is it
wrong assumption threat to international
security while other countries as
radical Islam or being better Teresa's
today.
We're going to answer that question,
but first let's take a look at the
history.
Great
thirst is lamach revolution until the
1970s it Roland was one of the most
glamorous dictatorships in the wells,
the so called sharp from Persia or
friends Mohammad Reza Pahlavi rules over
the country with an iron fist.
At the same time he and his wife are on
diva would go sit the magazine stars and
yes,
I said our friend there because the shah
of Persia was a great ally for the
United States as well as the free world.
Generally,
as we said a moment ago,
Iran holds the fourth largest oil
reserves in the world.
Plus they have over 80 million
inhabitants,
Sandy,
highly educated population when compared
to the neighboring countries.
Further there,
ron is a crucial spot for controlling
the Middle East region.
Nonetheless,
while the Shah was traveling all across
the world in drawing a lifestyle that
would make Kanye West look humble,
his country was getting ready for a
revolution and a surname.
I ones out.
What sorts of revolution like this be?
Was it a communist revolution or perhaps
it was an Islamic one?
Well,
initially the Uranian opposition was
pretty varied.
Unlike Saudi Arabia,
they're wrong,
or as it was known before,
the Persian empire had a long history as
well as a sophisticated
hold on.
So among these opposition groups,
you could find pre western liberals,
Marxists,
Social Democrats,
and of course,
radical isn't.
It assists the latter.
Just handle one indifference and bad to
the others.
They had a leader,
the Ayatollah Khomeini displaying living
in exile in Paris.
He had great charisma and a reputation
among via radio,
poop is in Paris.
Kamini addressed all of these things
ellucian raise in Iran,
encouraging them to take power with
them,
promise of a new and democratic Iran and
Iran were Marxists liberals and isn't it
as could all live together,
and this is how the Islamic Revolution
was born.
November of 1979 revolutionary forces
took over the government palace and the
u s embassy in Tehran.
This is actually the basis of the movie
argo starring Ben Affleck.
In this movie,
you can see the story of the American
workers at the embassy being taken
hostage by the Iranians.
Right afterwards,
the Ayatollah Khomeini would come back
to his country,
supported by all of his believers,
and this is what he said during his
first speech.
There is no need for an Islamic
democracy.
It is enough with Islam.
It was of course,
to eliminate the other revolutionary
groups that it helps them take a power.
All of those western liberals,
those Marxists,
those social democrats and even moderate
Muslims were excluded from the new
Islamic republic as of course,
the country's relationship with the
United States was totally broken.
Well,
actually it was only kinds of broken in
a way.
We could say there's America and Z.
Iran when from being friends to being
gets complicated.
Now,
on one hand committee hated the u s but
on the other hand was Ronald Reagan.
The American presidents at the time was
selling weapons to the Iranians so they
could fight against them.
Neighboring country rock.
Remember Saddam Hussein?
Well,
he was a common enemy for those
Khomeini,
Dan Duncan,
Sandy,
1997 the uranians chose a new presidents
Mohammed cut harming,
who tried to restore friendly
relationships with the US,
but at the same time,
the supreme leader who was not Khomeini
anymore,
but this other one you see on the
screen,
the Ayatollah Khomeini,
who had an evergreen obsession with
Israel.
So he was funding a terrorist
organization called [inaudible].
Cool.
Now,
don't forget that any Rhombi ultimate
decision maker,
this is not the president's,
but this religious leader who holds the
position of head of state.
The says the American President,
Bill Clinton said he would never the
friend,
a country that doesn't want Israel to
exist.
Meanwhile,
the Ron remained.
They divided despite the majority of
their population being okay with a
radically Islamic leadership.
There is still a big secular movement in
the state.
Then in 2005 something happens that
would change the fate of Iran.
That forever.
Huh?
With Act Martinia judge,
despite what it looks like between the
ends of the 1990s and the start of the
new millennium,
Iran had flirted with moderation.
Even secularism,
they even passed a divorce or that
included separation of goods between
husband and wife.
Not only that,
but by the year 2006 50% of the country
students were female.
Of course,
Iran was still a systemic and be
violating human rights.
Women were forced to have their heads
covered and religious minorities wet the
bidding.
But don't forget,
we are talking about an Islamic republic
in neighboring Saudi Arabia when ons
even allowed to drive.
But as you can imagine,
this little corner of freedom had not so
many fans on the radical Islamic side of
the SPEC.
Sure.
So the Ayatollah Khomeini used all his
power to radicalize the public opinion
against the president,
yet they meet.
And this is how in 2005 this other guy
with an impossible to pronounce,
name won the elections would act.
Martinia judge is how a radical accounts
or reform process started in Iran
tortures.
Then detentions increased significantly
after this year,
at least chase down women who wouldn't
wear the head job properly and the whole
world was shocked by quotes like this
one.
Bye Daddy.
You don't want to have the of Hanjin
spas.
We don't have homosexuals like country.
The the ultimate concern for Washington,
it was the Uranian attempt to do build
their own nuclear bomb.
It's pretty scary to imagine the
possibilities when a government that
publicly declared their intention to
raise Israel from the map and to use
president denies the Holocaust,
has a new BUBBA,
Iran hates Saudi Arabia and other
relationships that would be complicated
by Iran having the bomb.
We're actually going to talk more about
the Iran Saudi Arabia relationship in an
upcoming video,
so be sure to subscribe to this channel.
Now,
if you don't want to miss that,
and this is the moment when American has
Iran changed their relationship status.
Once again,
this time that went from it's
complicated to,
okay,
dirty council and poses sanctions on
Iran for failure to holt uranium
enrichment,
the Islamic republic became a real
danger to international stability.
These sanctions were no small thing
either.
Number,
how Iran has the four for larger,
it's crude oil reserves in the wells.
Well,
the economy of Iran unsurprisingly does
rely on these exports.
So imagine what would happen when the
wealthiest countries in the world just
stopped buying as since January or
Ramian.
Government figures show the prices of
bread,
milk,
and meat have risen around 20% well,
the price of chicken has jumped about
80% since January.
Iranian government figures show the
prices of bread and milk and meats have
risen around 20% while the price of
chicken has jumped about 80% but do wait
for just a second because Oh yes,
the best is yet to come.
The economic crisis destroyed our
[inaudible] Janse reputation and his
successor and current President Hassan
Rouhani came to power under the promise
of liberal reforms and better
relationships with the West.
But this is where things started to get
very interesting.
Okay.
The Arab spring,
Iran is a Shia Islamic country.
Inside the Muslim world,
Shia Islam is a minority.
This is one of the reasons why the
Iranian ayatollah is have such a bad
relationship with the Sunni clergy in
Saudi.
Right
radio
is the reason why Iran is willing to do
whatever they can to fight dash,
also known as Islamic states.
Bosch is a Sunni Muslim terrorist
organization.
Add to this.
The fact is that once America removed
did strips from Iraq,
the Ifo,
Liz funded the new government in Baghdad
and we can explain the following serious
President Bashar Al Assad says,
the Liberation of Aleppo from terrorists
is not only a victory for the mask is,
but also adults who participated in the
fight against terror,
especially Ron and wash up.
The Iranian army is fighting Islamic
states,
both in Syria and in Iraq.
And this is both a help as well as a
threat to the United States.
No one wants to find one radical group
just for it to be replaced with a more
radical one.
And yes,
this explains why Obama has an interest
in building ties with them
wrong.
It was a pretty small but your fam
because he hit two targets with one
shot.
Now on the one hand is if I'm always
sending a signal to Saudi Arabia,
he was not willing to help and fight
dash on that hand,
he is saying whoever defeats the bad
guys will have a good relationship with
the u s moreover,
he would finally see it,
an agreement with Iran in order to stop
their nuclear program.
And this is how they close the famously
controversial Iranian nuclear deal under
the nuclear deal that we are allies and
partners reached with Iran last year.
Uh,
Ron will not get a tans on a nuclear
bomb.
The region,
the United States and the world will be
more secure nonetheless,
Obama success that Donald Trump wants to
stop this diplomatic process,
even though the courts have vetoed his
infamous Islam ban.
The fact that he included Iran on the
list of countries that cannot get into
America.
There's a clear signal.
He is slamming the door on Iran.
More importantly,
he's showing some love for Saudi Arabia,
but this is something we've covered in
another video.
And if you want to understand why Donald
Trump is such a good friend of the
Saudis,
click on this
video.
Now,
here is the big question.
Cam America restore their relationship
with Iran.
Is it worth it in order to encourage
around?
Yep.
More moderate and less radical.
You can leave your answer this question
in the comments below.
We'd love to know about this,
and don't forget that we published brand
new videos every Monday and Thursday,
so please don't forget to,
so you don't miss any of those videos.
And if you liked this video,
do give it a thumbs up as always.
I'll see you next.
Oh.